On peut faire
encore une fois s’il te plaît ?
♫ C'est pas ta vie
Pourquoi t'es impliqué ♫
Aïe aïe aïe !
J’ai juste oublié
que j’étais pas Beyoncé !
Hi everybody, salut tout...
Oh, les aisselles !
Salut, c'est Jason.
J'ai rencontré Chloé Kitembo.
Désolé, parce que y a un truc ici,
il me dérange trop.
Chloé Kitembo, ça te parle ?
Chloé Kitembo, c'est
une influenceuse belge de 26 ans...
qui a plus de 500 000 abonnés
sur Instagram
et pas loin de 200 000 sur YouTube.
Hello, tout le monde.
Bienvenue dans une nouvelle vidéo.
Et elle a décidé de nous raconter
ses échecs.
Ouh, ouh, ouh...
Je suis trop nulle.
- OK. Ça va, ou quoi ?
- Ça va bien, et toi ?
- OK, on va recommencer.
On va dire directement.
Comment était ton enfance ?
-Euh, mon enfance...
J'ai grandi avec ma mère.
J'avais une vie très simple.
Donc, j'allais à l'école
et le dimanche, j'allais à l'église.
Mais ouais, c'était cool.
Je ne me plains pas.
- Ouais ?
- Ouais. J'ai pas à me plaindre.
Quand t'étais petite, tu voulais pas
devenir influenceuse ?
- Non. Non, non.
Quand j'étais petite, beh, en fait,
j'aimais déjà trop
le monde artistique.
Donc un jour, je voulais devenir
une styliste, un jour, je voulais
devenir une danseuse.
Tu te sentais à ta place
à l'école ?
Non. Vraiment pas.
Chloé, elle a plus
un esprit créatif.
Alors l'école,
c'est pas trop son fort.
À la fin de la primaire,
elle a déjà redoublé une fois.
Et elle rêve d'une seule chose :
intégrer une école spécialisée
dans les arts.
Mais vous savez très bien,
les métiers artistiques
et les parents, ça fait deux.
Sa mère, elle a peur pour elle
qu'elle trouve pas de travail
en faisant un métier artistique.
Alors, classique, elle l'oriente
vers un lycée général.
Et, classique,
Chloé, elle finit par décrocher.
Je dis classique parce
que vous et moi, on sait très bien,
quand on choisit pas
notre orientation,
on finit toujours par décrocher.
- Tu rentres dans le secondaire.
- Ouais.
- À 12 ans.
- Mmh... Oui.
Euh, j'avais déjà doublé
une année, ouais.
D'accord, OK.
13 ans.
J'avais 13 ans, on va dire.
Je suis rentré à 14 ans.
J'étais en retard de ouf !
- J'étais en retard de ouf,
j'ai raté le bus !
Je suis arrivée en 5e et, au final,
les profs, ils m'ont dit
que je devais aller
dans une direction professionnelle.
Euh, plus précisément la vente
et j'ai dit non.
Fuck. Je pars.
Partir de l'école,
ça m'a vraiment fait du mal.
Je me suis sentie comme un échec.
J'ai dit : OK, là, j'ai échoué.
En fait, le fait de voir
tout le monde qui suit
un chemin classique et réussir
et toi,
t'es sur le bord de la route...
- C'était trop grave.
- Je connais.
Moi, je me rappelle,
c'était en septembre.
Et septembre, c'est la rentrée.
Et en fait, t'as tout le monde
qui va dans les meilleures écoles,
dans les meilleurs lycées de Paris.
Et toi, tu vois, t'es là...
avec les autres.
Et à ce moment-là, tu dis :
je crois que mon destin,
il est bien.
Il est au quartier, au final.
Je suis mort.
Tu te dis que là, c'est bon,
je suis mort.
J'ai pas réussi.
Tu commences quand,
les réseaux sociaux ?
- Euh, je commence les réseaux
un peu plus tard.
Je commence en 2012.
Elle décide alors de travailler
pour subvenir à ses besoins
et de se consacrer à son métier
d'influenceuse.
Non, c'est pas bon.
C'est pas bon.
Et de se consacrer entièrement
à son métier d'influenceuse
et à sa chaîne YouTube.
Salut tout le monde
et bienvenue sur ma chaîne.
Salut tout le monde,
rebienvenue sur ma chaîne.
Ce qui se passe, c'est que pendant
3 ans, elle gagne pas d'argent.
J'espère que vous avez kiffé
cette vidéo.
N'oubliez pas de liker
et vous abonner.
Tout ça sans agence, indépendante.
Dans ta tête,
est-ce que tu te dis...
Tu sais où tu vas ?
- Non. Non, absolument pas.
- Ça te fait peur ?
- Euh, non, ça me fait...
Ça me faisait pas peur...
parce que j'étais vraiment...
Bon, on va pas dire bornée,
mais voilà, je vivais pour moi,
en fait, je faisais
ce que je voulais,
parce que j'en avais besoin.
J'ai utilisé ce noir.
C'est vraiment un noir parfait.
Il est tellement... tellement noir.
J'ai vraiment fait organiquement,
tu vois.
J'ai appris.
Je suis tombée 10 fois, tu vois,
mais je me suis relevée.
Qu'est-ce qui t'a aidée
à te relever ?
Beh, la persévérance.
Tu te dis : OK, c'est...
Y a ça, mais c'est pas grave,
ça m'arrête pas.
On continue.
♫ Mmh, whatcha say? ♫
♫ Ooh, that you only meant well? ♫
Et tu rêvais toujours de faire
du chant, quelque part ?
Mmh, à cette époque-là,
je commençais à y penser.
Ça va, monsieur, vous allez bien ?
Super.
Après 3 ans de persévérance,
ça commence enfin
à marcher pour elle.
C'est ça que j'aime bien
avec Chloé, elle lâche rien.
Une marque de cosmétiques l'invite
au festival Coachella
à Los Angeles, en Californie,
pour y créer du contenu.
En gros, pour kiffer.
Et cette année-là
avec Beyoncé en headline.
Beyoncé !
Ça a réveillé
quelque chose en elle.
Cette envie de se lancer
dans la musique,
c'est revenu dans son cœur.
♫ I like my baby, hey, baby, hey ♫
Alors, Chloé, elle revient
et elle se remet à enregistrer.
Elle était à fond,
mais elle a jamais rien sorti.
Parce qu'elle trouvait pas en elle
cette force pour assumer son rêve.
L'influencing, ça commençait à...
Pas à m'ennuyer, mais y a un truc
qui me manquait.
Je me voyais pas faire ça
toute ma vie, en fait.
♫ Mmh, to the left, to the left ♫
♫ Everything you own
In a box to the left ♫
Le côté musique, qui était...
en fait...
Il m'a toujours fait coucou,
mais j'ai toujours un peu...
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
En fait, tu l'as tellement renié
qu'au final,
tu sais pas quel était
le vrai problème ?
Voilà. "Renié", c'est ça.
♫ Somebody ♫
♫ Who will stand by me ♫
T'as vraiment commencé
à te lancer en 2021.
Qu'est-ce qui a été l'élément
déclencheur ?
Euh, beh, en fait, je commençais.
Parce que j'étais vraiment en train
de procrastiner la musique.
Et en fait, ça commençait
à jouer sur mon mental.
Je me sentais mal.
Y avait quelque chose
qui n'allait pas,
mais j'arrivais pas à...
Je me disais : mais ça peut pas être
la musique, quand même.
Ne me dis pas que si je fais
de la musique,
je vais être heureuse.
Mais en fait, c'était ça.
♫ She calls out
To the man on the street ♫
♫ Sir, can you help me? ♫
Et donc en 2021,
tu le trouves où, ce courage,
ce déclic, en fait ?
Ce qui fait que tu te dis :
vas-y, j'y vais.
Mais déjà, je le trouve
à partir du moment où :
c'est pas tout ce que tu vas faire
qui doit être parfait, déjà.
Parce que déjà,
t'es dans les débuts.
Bien sûr que ça va pas être parfait.
Et il faut assumer ce truc-là.
- Donc t'as fait ton 1er clip...
- Mmh.
- En anglais ?
- Ouais.
♫ Can't stop my shine ♫
Pendant toutes ces années, j'ai été
confrontée à des situations,
des personnes, même des relations,
toutes ces choses-là ont fait
en sorte que...
en fait, m'ont poussée...
vers mon but.
Et c'est comme ça
que t'évolues, je trouve.
Quand t'as un obstacle,
tu regardes pas...
OK, y a la difficulté
de l'obstacle et tout, mais après,
qu'est-ce que t'en tires ?
Moi, je trouve, ça, c'est très beau.
Et si je te demandais un secret
pour réaliser ses rêves ?
Un secret pour réaliser
ses rêves...
Je pense qu'il faut rester connecté
à soi-même.
Toujours.
- Merci, Chloé.
- Merci, Jason.
Merci à toi.
T'as déjà vu...
T'as déjà vu un bébé...
T'as déjà vu un bébé ne jamais
tomber en apprenant à marcher ?
Chloé, elle est comme moi,
elle est comme toi,
elle est comme nous tous.
C'est ça que j'aime bien
avec elle.
C'est en tombant qu'on apprend
à marcher.
Je perds jamais.
Soit je gagne, soit j'apprends.
Ah oui, j'oubliais.
Abonne-toi à la chaîne Brut.
Et si t'as des personnes
que tu veux que je contacte,
t'as un influenceur que tu kiffes,
tu veux que j'aille lui parler,
t'as un footballeur,
tu veux que je lui parle,
t'as un danseur,
t'as un président,
tu veux que je lui parle ?
Envoie-moi un DM,
mets en commentaire sur YouTube,
peu importe,
mais viens, on discute ensemble.
Viens, on parle.
Viens, c'est notre chaîne.
Viens, on se tape des barres.
Et viens, c'est que nous.